hey everybody this is Gary Vaynerchuk  with your social media State of the  Union update I don't I just made that up  but I'm gonna be the universe of my vana  folks I just want to make a statement  quick little video just trying to help  marketers out there it is a definitive  statement so get ready if you were  targeting the 13 to 20 year olds I just  want to clarify it for you right now the  only thing they give a crap about right  now from storytelling platforms the way  I look at them is Instagram and snapchat  vine as well a little bit those two  rates Instagram snapchat and vine this  is not a Facebook Twitter conversation  for that demo so you're just learning  about Facebook and Twitter and it's  already passing you by understand what's  going on there if you're trying to reach  them